coach first of all you're the first
guest we've ever had where I say thank
you for sending me your pants they look
nice thank you for the khakis awesome
yeah you gotta pack it in there uh not
yet studio I'm gonna get him how I'm
gonna get him quite make the studio cat
not yet I'm gonna get a mannequin and
I'm gonna put the Manukau put her on the
mannequin and the pullover but i was
told game-used khakis what game was then
I don't know offhand what good game that
was but i am not offended that they're
not in the studio you got a lot of a lot
of nice stuff in your studio no no no no
they're not in the studio to make the
cut they're not in the studio are there
in the studio they're just not hung
they're not properly displayed but they
will be it's gonna be the the Harbaugh
mannequin I was gonna wear them socially
I was gonna wear the khakis out we r
prime very similar similar now I think
you're a little bigger than I open yeah
you're a little better now we have a bed
here dinner is is gonna hinge on this do
you know what spinning is the exercise
spinning yeah they did some the bicycle
there we go Paulie you are getting
dinner tonight double or nothing if
coach has ever done it I'm gonna say
okay go around the room who thinks jim
harbaugh is done spinning quick little
impromptu a question will way no no I
Paulie there's he know why not I'm gonna
say yes that you've done spinning no way
oh I've ridden a bike and rid of an
exercise bike but no I've never gone to
a spinning class hey hey what do you
mention these days that much you know
bench the bench was never mind it's
never my best exercise uh [ __ ] you
what are you wretched good guy throwing
around 90 95 somewhere around there okay
right about there with you I'll tell you
what though if we're doing curls with
beers I'm right there I'm one of them
I'm a heavyweight with blister there I'm
Olympic there got your technique yes
do yes I do I that had to be pretty cool
that Brady goes to the big house brings
his son up there did you do you know
that he was going to be up there having
some fun prior to the game oh oh yeah
yeah that was some time about ecotec
where I'm honorary captains for the game
and then both couldn't have been better
time of it Tom being back in Michigan
Stadium the way he interacted with with
our players with with the students with
the width with us with our crowd and the
way they they treated here was special
it was special special day for Michigan
football what did he talk to the kids
prior to the game he did the and it was
as a pregame talked at that you would
expect from Tom Brady it was the paint
was peeling from the little inside the
walls of the locker room him he he hit
him and he resonated with him and it was
one of the better better pregame
speeches I've ever heard a coach or
player towel it was it was from the
heart and it was exactly what they
needed to hear that segues me into Jay
Cutler in his demeanor you played in
that town of Chicago and and I know that
it's you know everybody's critiquing
color I'm not asking you to do that as
much as the demeanor of the quarterback
and how other players feed off of that
the Jay doesn't he's not demonstrative
whereas you were probably the other way
around in that city how important is
that for you you know your players to
see if your quarterbacks happier he's
sad or he's a leader or whatever it
might be that they see that personality
my answer that is be honest and true
when it's you play with all players play
with in their personality the
personality is very little to do with to
me how a quarterback performs or how
they're how they're treated or how their
respected by their teammates I mean you
respect people that that are who they
are and play
it has the personality that they have so
you know by your effort by your talent
that's that's how you're known but also
if public ball player and a quarterback
if Cutler was successful we would look
at his personality differently we'd Sabo
that's a cool customer man he doesn't
let anything bother him that that we
almost you know we can look at it and
say like Belichick Bella check shows no
emotion but there's no better coach in
in the in football than him so we'll say
you know what he's not going to let you
have it I was just talking to talking to
people to know him I mean his teammates
and and I actually do know Jay Cutler
I've been been around Jay Cutler many
times I'm he is a is a serious guy he is
a hard worker he is I watched him coach
at our camp the last two summers in a
row and means he's outstanding so I
think people have speculated don't know
i mean that's that's just speculation
it'll know somebody unless you know he's
jim hor baa michigan head coach if you
really wonder ask us ask his teammates
well you do hear some that's the only
thing in there there ones and sometimes
it'll be anonymous but they do you know
if it seems like an anonymous somebody
somebody tells a story but they don't
put their name to it I would it's a
bunch of hogwash and let anybody that
has a has a good story to tell I mean
they they want to attach their name to
it the ones where the guy goes anonymous
off the record I mean I give that no
credibility Jim Harbaugh Michigan head
coach next up will be Penn State this
weekend we just had a quarterback draft
you can start your franchise any
quarterback you got to have them for
seven years though coach what
quarterback would you take now if yet
it's new franchise Tim you got the first
pick your quarterback would be for the
next seven years is who Andrew Luck who
said that click how come uh that would
be my pick oh I didn't know sometimes
you know ask the guy who made the pic
why'd you pick and her look
he's raced and yeah he's a complete he's
a total stud oh okay we thought you were
going to take brady even at Brady's age
that was that was our guest I go I'll go
Andrew did you would you make of them
you got me in the rare that i hate to
compare though because there's so many
good ones i mean you start comparing one
to another and then it's somebody always
gets diminished but i would feel good
about if i had to pick I would take any
luck would you make of I don't know how
much pressure was but Central Michigan
should have done the right thing to give
Oklahoma State that win back we don't
even know if they were able to buy the
n-c-double-a but what did you make of
that where Oklahoma State lost the game
in Central Michigan somehow should have
given it back I'll make anything of that
I really i just gotta gotta gotta get
more familiar with that role just the
exact ins and outs of that that role so
before well nobody else knew it either
that reminds good reminder i need
anything really before the day is over
I'm going to really dig deep into that
role how many games do you need before
you understand how good your team is to
the personality of your team I think hit
to know your team better better better
each game with each game you get to you
know your team better just like with
people you know the more you more you're
rounding the know you the more you
really known we we use your expression
by the way who's got it better than us
your dad's expression yes we know the
answer to that one well when these guys
wine and they'll complain about the work
conditions here or they got to stay
later and then Paulie who's got it
better than us yeah no nobody does
nobody nobody nobody's got a better in
fair life milk there you go segue here
comes the pitch go ahead fire away coach
wow i just did be great if you could go
to go to youtube and watch my wife Sarah
and the kids were we did a couple videos
for fair life milk and
that's my and I also want to say happy
birthday can you segue to this happy
birthday to my wife Sarah so of all the
things you could have thought to give
your wife you gave her a birthday
greeting in the Dan Patrick show that's
been chopping up in a fridge full of
fair life Malcolm president yeah once
again that my wife she is she's the best
and I want to thank her mom Alta and
heard Admiral for for having her for
having her I think the next win after
you beat Penn State no Gatorade
fairlight milk poured on your head
that's we already do it we already do we
got out we got a big big milk dispenser
of we have chocolate milk we have whole
melt and fellows even talked me into two
percent which is it's better than
nothing the two percent urban meyer
drinks one percent by the way well we
refused to drink the candy ass skim milk
or the one percent we refuse oh we won't
have any of that Patrick Harbaugh oh
damn we still get the biggest kick out
of your dad when he came in that day at
big right hand to his Patrick Harbaugh
oh it could have cashed your dad in a
movie man Oh awesome thanks for the
khakis we're gonna get him on a
mannequin proudly displayed and thanks
again for joining us oh thanks for
having me you're one of the best damn
thank you but that's Jim Harbaugh
Patrick Harbaugh a continental tire
coaches corner brought to you by
Continental Tire you'll see continental
tired sporting venues across the United
States proud supporter of the imsa
racing Major League Soccer college
basketball Continentals premium products
available leading independent tire
dealers car dealers in mass retail
companies across North America for more
information visit Continental Tire calm
continental tire for what you do
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience